The president of the United States said yesterday
in North Carolina that voter.
Jurors should try to vote twice.
He actually said you should go out there in
North Carolina.
Mail in a vote.
And then on Election Day, go and try to vote.
Now, Donald Trump is suggesting this as a
sort of test of our election system.
Donald Trump has tried to make the public
believe that our voting systems are so terrible,
so antiquated, so bogus, that people could
easily get away with mailing in a ballot and
then going and voting, and then your vote
is counted twice.
Now, if the systems are working correctly,
I've explained this to you.
If you have sent in a ballot and then you
go in to vote in person, it will show up.
You've already voted.
We've already received your ballot via absentee.
If the opposite happens, imagine for a moment
that you send in a ballot via mail.
But it hasn't been received on Election Day.
You go in and vote on Election Day and you're
allowed to.
And then the next day, your mail in ballot
is received.
That ballot would not be counted because you've
already been checked off as having voted.
Now, of course, in a country of 331 million.
Anything can happen.
And anecdotally, there are probably some cases
of double votes getting by people much like
there are cases of voting machines going wrong.
And you press one person and accidentally,
you know, or because of manipulation, as some
would say, casts a ballot for the other guy
or gal.
It's a country of 331 million people.
But the idea that that's wide spread and the
idea that that's a good way to win an election
is absolutely laughable.
Well, it's also a felony in North Carolina.
And here is Donald Trump encouraging voters
to commit a crime.
Take a look at this.
Well, they'll go out and they'll vote and
they're going to have to go and check their
vote by going to the polls and voting that
way, because if it if it tabulates, then they
won't be able to do that.
So let them send it in and let them go.
Vote out of their systems.
As good as they say it is, then obviously
they won't be able to vote.
If it isn't tabulated, they'll be able to
vote.
So that's the way it is.
But send in your ballots sentiments strong,
whether it's solicited or unsolicited.
The absentees are fine.
We have to work to get them, you know, something
and you send them in, but you go to vote.
And if they haven't counted it, you could
vote.
So that's the way I view it.
So this is a crime.
This is a crime.
The law actually says intentionally double
voting is a crime.
Put aside the fact that it really would not
work unless something goes wrong.
As I as I mentioned earlier, if you mail it
in, you wouldn't be allowed to get an in-person
ballot.
If you vote in person and then a mail in ballot
comes in, the mail in ballot would be considered
spoiled.
But this is a felony in North Carolina.
And in an interview last year, Kim, who who's
the secretary of state in Washington State,
where they've been doing vote by mail for
years, she said that these double voting scenarios
are extremely rare.
She said, quote, We can usually run our list
of people who have appeared to vote more than
once out of three point five million ballots
in 2018.
It appears one hundred people may have voted
more than once.
Counties are checking 100 people out of three
point five million ballots.
And, of course, of those hundred, many of
them were record.
This is the number of people who tried to
vote more than once.
And Kim Whyman added.
Is it perfect?
No.
Is there rampant fraud?
Do people sometimes make mistakes?
Yes.
Now, here's the kicker.
Donald Trump is not only suggesting that voters
commit a crime because it is a crime to willfully
go and try to vote twice.
Donald Trump committed a crime.
Donald Trump was in North Carolina where when
he said this.
And in North Carolina, it is a felony for,
quote, any person with intent to commit a
fraud, to register or vote at more than one
precinct or more than one time or to induce
another to do so.
So voting more than once is against the law
and is a felony in North Carolina and suggesting
to other people that they do it is also a
crime in North Carolina.
And voting more than once is also illegal
under federal law.
And all of this is really focused around doing
one thing, cast doubt on election results
in advance so that if it's close, if it's
not close, quite frankly, no matter what the
results are, Donald Trump will be able to
say, I've been telling you all along, I've
been telling you all along, it's rigged, rigged,
rigged.
And that's exactly what he's doing.
Trump is committing crimes in front of cameras
in order to do it.
And who knows how many of his supporters are
going to be induced to commit a crime based
on what Donald Trump said yesterday.
We have to end this.
We have to get this malignancy out of the
White House.
And he's going to do anything he can think
of announcing the vaccine, suggesting people
test the system, dissuading people from voting,
post office, foreign meddling.
It's all in play and we have to overwhelm
the vote in order to prevent it.
You know that that's the way to do it at this
point, eight weeks out.
I know that it's the way to
do it as well.